let's and you know i have not spoken to
my father
in almost three months so for father's
day i thought it'd be very nice
to call my father on the show let's give
him a ring and we'll see what happens
i've not spoken to my dad in two months
it's almost three
hey slot oh my god you caught me at the
weirdest time
oh my god my slave is here and he's like
with the script and he's being
dominatrix it's insane hold on one
second
oh my god he wants me to sit on this
nutribullet
oh my god hi
hi dad happy father's day how are you
hey flop so i'm doing pretty bad i'm
just stuck here with my slave and he
split the script and he's seeing my
dominatrix it's insane so
i don't understand so he you usually
dominate him oh my god
yes he's tired of the slave he's being
[ __ ] crazy right now
oh my god he wants me to sit on this
nutribullet again do you think i should
do it
should i do it i mean it's father's day
this is crazy
happy oh my god you're such a sweetheart
for calling hold on one second
oh my god by the way how's school hold
on one second
oh my god oh my god i'm so scared
it's the big cup okay hold on
oh yes yes
oh my god oh jesus christ
it smells like alyssa milano's [ __ ]
in here oh my god it's fun though thank
you so much for calling
i mean how are you it's good is this
safe is everything you're doing
safe oh my god please don't worry this
happens all the time here
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] he just hit me in the
[ __ ] with a pan
oh my god this is crazy
this is like a service that you you have
come to your home
oh my god yes listen enough about me how
are you how's austin do you like it
i i'm you know it's an adjustment i
think i'm going back to la i think it's
more mystery
it's beautiful what are you saying it's
beautiful and austin and the talent
there oh my god
timothy stay give it a chance i i don't
think i can
oh my god he won't i am not putting that
down the garbage compactor
oh my god timothy is this a bad time
no no why don't i call you back
it's a great it's a
great time uh i just want to wish you
happy father you know we hadn't talked
in a while i wanted to make sure
that everything was okay
yeah this i is not sitting on that
oh my god timothy it's your high school
trophy i cherish that
no let's sit on it is this okay timothy
yes if if you have to do it you can do
it we've got to lube it up i have to
he's
he's in charge i'm supposed to be the
one in charge of insane
oh my god you did so good on the soccer
tournament
okay i've got the head i'm down
by the waist oh timothy i'm so sorry i
know you love this
we'll clean it up oh god well i'm glad
you're having a good weekend
thank you so much for calling it's so
sweet and um i hope you and
you know this power dynamic between you
and the dominatrix i hope
you guys figure that out oh my god
i hope it flips at some point oh god
thank you so much for calling and thank
you for the flowers it's so sweet
yes well well you're you're i appreciate
it and give them to your wife
oh my god i have to go timothy but god
bless you for calling yes thank you
happy father's day
sweetheart good luck at school thank you
that is my
father um um
[Music]
he seems well he seems like he's doing
it he's doing the right thing and
you know um
you know hey
just happy that he's doing well yeah he
seems good
he's very good okay well happy father's
day to everyone out there and i hope
your dad is
having as much fun as mine